Speaker 1: failed former President Donald
Trump, was given the opportunity to respond
to Kanye West's anti-Semitic comments. Now, this
was an interesting question. This was with Larry
O'Connor, Joe O'Connor, Larry O'Connor from the
Salem News Channel. And Kanye has praised Trump
before. And when you praise Trump, Trump will
rarely criticize you no matter what you do, no
matter what you say. Even though Donald Trump has
a Jewish daughter by conversion and a Jewish son
in law and Jewish grandkids and all this stuff.
Trump, we know, harbors many anti-Semitic beliefs,
but he's also not. Going to attack Kanye over.
This would be my guess because Kanye is nice
to Trump and likes Trump. And indeed, Trump
downplayed Kanye's anti-Semitic comments. In
this just complete implosion of an interview.
Speaker 2: He's been saying some really odd
offensive things lately about your own son in
law, Jared Kushner, and about Jewish people.
Jewish Americans.
Speaker 1: Yeah,
he's attacking your family writ large.
Speaker 2: Could you react to that?
Because is this the guy that you knew?
Speaker 4: Well, I haven't really seen
the statements he's made.
Speaker 1: Give me a break.
Speaker 4: Did did watch the Tucker
Carlson interview. And he was really
nice to me.
Speaker 1:
That's what that's all that matters. That's all
that matters. Listen, the anti-Semitic comments,
including the ones against my own son in law that
I didn't see, but he had great reviews for me when
he spoke to Tucker. And by the way, Tucker cut out
anti-Semitic elements of that interview as well,
which we later obtained beyond anybody.
Speaker 4: He was. He was great to me. And he
was great, really, to MAGA, to the MAG, which was
very impressive. I was, you know, not surprised.
I always got along with him. I liked him. I've
always gotten along with him. So I don't really
know what statements he made. Sometimes he'll make
a statement and a lot of people will think it's
worse, that he means it to be right guys.
Speaker 1: Carney's overtly anti-Semitic
statements, including listing a dozen
different anti-Semitic tropes in that
drink. Whatever interview that I
played for you earlier this week,
it was all blown up and taken out of context.
Speaker 4: I think that, you know, I was I was
certainly very you know, what I'm talking about.
He was really high on a guy named Donald Trump.
He's been saying some of Trump's approaches.
Speaker 1: I don't care what he says
as long as he's nice to me that
that's fundamentally what it is.
Let's look at a little bit more of this interview.
The entire interview was bizarre together.
Speaker 2: Let's get all of
those questions answered.
I'm very proud to be joined by the 45th
president, Donald Trump. Mr. President,
thank you for joining us tonight.
Speaker 4: Well, thank you very much,
Larry. Well, I know that.
Speaker 2: You're focusing on the
2022 primaries. You're doing your your rallies.
And I know that there's a lot of candidates that
you single handedly endorse. The latest polling
shows a red wave coming. How much credit do you
think you deserve for what's about to happen?
Speaker 1: That's a that's a really good question.
To open it up with how much should we be praising
you for any Republican win in November, sir?
Speaker 4: Well, I think we deserve a lot of
credit for having done a really good job over
four years, that we had no inflation. We
had the greatest economy in the history of
our country. We had the strongest border ever.
We defeated ISIS. We would have never had the
catastrophe that's going on in Ukraine. That was
not something that would ever have happened 100%.
We were energy independent. We were going to be
energy dominant in a period of very short period
of time. Right. You know, we would have been
supplying the world with energy. We would have
made a fortune. We would have brought down the
taxes and many other things that we rebuilt the
military and a lot of a lot of things that we did.
Speaker 1: Was that 12 lies in 90 seconds? Is that
is that actually what I just heard?
So as you can imagine, not exactly.
Significant journalistic rigor during this very
strange interview. But listen, if you're nice to
Trump, you can get away with saying anything. Even
overtly anti-Semitic comments about Trump's own
son in law must be nice to just have that simple
moral guidepost. If they say nice things about me,
I'll say nice things about them. We'll
take a quick break and be back after this